oui
keumayou bonsoir bonsoir [musique] nous
vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne youtube il s'appelle singer view
on vous reçoit dans lequel de votre
activité du journalisme et plus
spécialement sur l'afrique oui est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement oui bien sûr je suis louis
magyar keumayou je suis journaliste
indépendant
sujet pigiste donc et je travaille sur
les sujets relatifs à l'afrique de façon
générale est ce que je pourrais ajouter
sexuée président du club de
l'information africaine qui est une
association du journaliste avec pour
centre d'intérêt commun l'afrique est ce
que vous pouvez revenir un peu sur votre
passé de journaliste vous avez travaillé
ou combien de temps et dans quelles
boîte ah c'est vrai qu'il ya pas mal
d'expérience j'ai commencé le
journalisme déjà au cameroun en amateur
mais là probablement ça compte pas
puisqu'il s'agit pas de la phase
professionnels le message et c'est ça le
message mais ça c'était déjà et si en
france parce que j'ai commencé au
cameroun en amateur jusqu'à l'université
j'ai fait une année d'université je me
suis retrouvé en russie puis en ukraine
caisse à kiev notamment où j'ai commencé
comme correspondant pour la fp avant de
travailler aussi pour une radio sur
place
radio supernova puis radio quotidienne
qui est aussi une radio chrétienne et
c'est au terme de tout cela que je me
suis retrouvé en france je suis reparti
au cameroun et en revenant il était
correspondante d'abord du message et
puis de mutation qui sont du quotidien
camerounais ensuite j'ai travaillé pour
radio vatican pendant quatre ans à peu
près réussi la bbc pour l'afrique est
une chaîne de télévision qui s'appelle
télésud c'est la dernière vous avez été
envoyée j'ai été oui j'ai été limogé de
mon poste de directeur de l'information
a requis par un ancien tf1 qui s'appelle
bernard volker et qui est le directeur
de télé su depuis un certain nombre
d'années maintenant depuis à peu près 7
ans et
raffi et refi ça a été ma première
grosse expérience parce que c'était mon
partenaire
quand j'étais en ukraine et que j'avais
des émissions
culturelle à la radio cela me permettait
d'avoir des disques parce qu'elle a à
l'époque il avait ce qu'il appelait les
gee-gees volant qui permettait
d'alimenter les radios en dvd à l'époque
c'est d'être et thématique sur la
musique africaine caribéenne française
et ainsi de suite donc après toutes ces
expériences clair ma première expérience
en france a été au sein de la rédaction
de rfi avant d'aller à l'école de
journalisme du cfpj à la rue du louvre
est ce que vous connaissez la charte de
munich il en a entendu parler qu'est ce
que vous pouvez nous ils nous ont dit on
mais je sais que c'est un garde-fou qui
permet aux journalistes de respecter un
certain nombre de critères
déontologiques dans la pratique du
métier cette
charte a quand même beaucoup souffert 1
depuis que la crise des médias comment
c'est que aujourd'hui sur le financement
on tend à ne plus être aussi exigeant
qu'on l'a été dans le passé et donc du
coup il nous reste que la clause de
conscience finalement pour pour sauver
la charte de munich voilà donc on fait
avec on
rentre dans le vif du sujet est ce que
il ya un nouveau thomas sankara en
afrique j'espère
que c'est thomas sankara là ne sera pas
assassiné alors qu'ils par les forces
qui ne voudront pas que ses idées
progressent comme malheureusement celle
de thomas sankara qui est tombé à la
fleur de l'âge je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il ya il ya une nécessité pour l'afrique
de se renouveler le problème c'est que
la plupart du temps les velléités de
renouvellement que nous avons sur le
continent africain sont éteintes par les
besoins quotidiens liés à l'immédiate
était liée aux contingences de la vie de
tous les jours et donc malheureusement
ça ne marche pas et donc les gens ont
une tendance très simple c'est que c'est
de se rattacher au passé au passé de la
négritude au passé des pères de
l'indépendance au passé de tout ce qui
était relativement mieux qu'aujourd'hui
est donc finalement on ne produit plus
malheureusement et donc j'espère qu'on
aura à nouveau des dirigeants qui auront
ce [grognement] souci de se démarquer
des vicissitudes du quotidien pour avoir
une vision à long terme pour leur pays
pour le continent et donc pour pour les
africains pour l'humanité tout
simplement parce que au-delà d'être
africain on est des hommes
je pense que notre mission sur terre
c'est pas juste de défendre un bout de
terrain aussi grand et prestigieux soit
il c'est de faire que l'humanité
progresse de façon générale donc
actuellement il ya probablement du point
de vue de ces idées là le président
rwandais par exemple qui n'est pas un
exemple cité en occident mais qui de mon
point de vue au regard de ce qu'il fait
dans son pays est un modèle on à nana
akufo addo au niveau du ghana qui
essaient ils lui aussi d'apporter une
renouvellement au niveau de la scène
politique africaine et c'est pas
surprenant que ça vient du ghana parce
que le père du panafricanisme est
quand même sorti de là donc c'est à peu
près normal que avec le avec l'évolution
de l'histoire l'on retrouve à nouveau un
dirigeant ghanéen qui à ce souci à la
fois de bâtir son pays d'aider à la
construction des états unis d'afrique
est aussi de faire en sorte que d'avoir
des relations normales avec le reste du
monde tant que les valeurs communes que
nous avons en tant qu'êtres humains sur
la planète sont respectées je pense que
c'est salutaire vous parlez de relations
avec les reste du monde la
chine et la russie sont bien implantées
en afrique quelle perception les
africains ont des chinois et des russes
est ce que c'est la même perception que
l'aspect
colonialiste occidental
commençons avec la sphère francophone de
l'afrique parce que c'est vrai que les
relations ne sont pas les mêmes selon
que l'on est en angola au cameroun au
congo ou ailleurs dans l'afrique
francophone les chinois ont été une
véritable bouée de sauvetage pour une
raison très simple c'est que on a connu
dans les années 80 et surtout dans les
années 90 avec la dévaluation du franc
cfa la chute du mur de berlin et la fin
de la guerre froide on a connu une
période où l'afrique avait disparu de la
carte du monde géopolitique
personne ne croyait plus en afrique
l'afro pessimisme était à son paroxysme
et donc pour l'afrique c'était très
difficile et il fallait trouver de
nouveaux partenaires pour être au coeur
des enjeux internationaux à la fois de
géopolitique de développement la france
a lâché l'afrique il faut dire les
choses comme elles sont qui la france la
france et le gouvernement de l'époque
c'était la droite qui était au pouvoir
et donc il ya une dévaluation du franc
cfa 2 50% et puis des baisses de
salaires qui ont accompagné cela on a
parlé de mesures d'accompagnement qui ne
sont jamais arrivées l'afrique a eu la
france ait eu l'impression qu'en allant
vers l'est elle trouverait ce qu'elle
n'avait plus en afrique est donc ce sont
les chinois qui ont pris le relais à
cette époque là et qui ont permis aux
africains non seulement de compenser
leur pouvoir d'achat qui avait
drastiquement baissé mais également de
re devenir un élément important dans le
jeu politique internationale donc je
pense que on peut reprocher beaucoup de
choses aux chinois n'ont pas manqué de
rappeler que s'il n'avait pas été là
peut-être que pour l'afrique francophone
la fête du franc cfa on se serait
retrouvé dans une situation carrément
ingérable et des émeutes sont censurés
suis vite je sais pas si on aurait eu
pire que le génocide au rwanda le
génocide des tutsi mais ce qui est
certain c'est que le rôle des chinois
pour cette époque-là a été crucial pour
stabiliser les pays africains la russie
quant à la russie c'est la guerre froide
pour la période où la russie l'union
soviétique à l'époque à utiliser
également les jeux de positionnement
l'afrique pour régler ses comptes
patrice lumumba était notamment une
icône dans dans cela il ya une
université à moscou qui porte son nom
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui la russie
essaye de retrouver ce passé qui a été
très important pour lui des relations
avec l'afrique où beaucoup d'africains
allait poursuivre leurs études en russie
mais n'y vont plus aujourd'hui pour une
raison très simple c'est que la chute du
mur de berlin et l'implosion de la
russie ont fait que certains sentiments
les néo l'ailé
les racistes tout simplement et les
restes tu sais plus comment les appels
mais ces espèces de raciste qui
pullulent aujourd'hui dans les anciennes
républiques soviétiques ont rendu la vie
impossible aux africains dans ce pays là
que ce soit en russie ou dans d'autres
républiques soviétiques et
malheureusement ça deviendrait répulse
pour les africains mais cela n'empêche
pas que dans certains pays d'afrique est
aujourd'hui comme la république
centrafricaine le rôle de la russie soit
plutôt bien perçues notamment pour
lutter contre les forces militaires
incontrôlés des réveillons est ce que
vous voyez des échanges en guinée et en
oublient merger ça commence ça commence
en one we en roubles un peu moins parce
que il n'ya pas de les relations ne sont
plus si forte que cela entre la russie
et l'afrique mais en revanche avec la
chine qui a pris une très grosse avance
à la fois sur le plan politique mais
aussi sur le plan financier les
relations sont très fortes la chine
vient de promettre un quasi doublement
de son aide publique au développement
pour l'afrique elles interviennent
beaucoup dans la construction des
infrastructures est donc là où les
occidentaux les pays dits développés et
démocratique pose des conditions pour
l'aide et même pour construire des
chantiers les chinois font des choses
qui parle aux africains parce que c'est
du concret cette notion de gagnant
gagnant même si elle n'est pas toujours
vérifiables elle parle aux africains et
elle leur donne une lueur d'espoir quant
à l'avenir des relations et surtout du
développement du continent noir thomas
sankara sa [grognement]
pensée de répudier la dette est
ce qu'il ya un leader africain qui qui
a pris ce chemin de la voir même avant
même de parler de répudier la dette je
pense qu'il ya quelque chose de très
important que thomas sankara est dit une
chose très importante qui l'a dit c'est
que on ne peut pas vivre au dessus de
ses moyens et la plupart des pays
africains vivent au dessus de leurs
moyens et canaux dans la grande majorité
si je m'en tiens au jus stopper de la
zone ses fins nous vendons en dollars
nous achetons en euros c'est déjà une
absurdité en soit nous commerçons
beaucoup avec la chine et
malheureusement notre monnaie et à une
parité fixe avec l'euro ce qui nous
pénalise quand nous devons nous devons
vendre et surtout quand tu dois acheter
et donc tout notre produit tout le
développement de l'afrique dont on parle
parce qu'on parle souvent des taux de
croissance de du continent africain qui
sont enviables et qui approuve souvent
les deux chiffres mais toute cette
richesse là elle va à ceux qui sont
riches déjà elle va pas aux plus pauvres
et elle va surtout aux entreprises qui
sont sur le continent africain et qui
rapatrient leurs bénéfices
malheureusement à l'extérieur donc c'est
une richesse tout à fait artificielle
qui ressemble à un mirage on on voit la
richesse passée mais elles traversent
nos foyers elles traversent nos pays
pour aller servir d'autres économies qui
sont pas africaine le franc cfa quelle
perception de [souffle coupé]
cette monnaie antiques comme un pou
jeune afrique je pense que les africains
sont
en train aujourd'hui de se tromper de
combat quand ils font une fixette sur le
franc cfa pour une raison simple le
français fait une monnaie coloniale
c'était le franc des colonies françaises
d'afrique nous sommes près de 60 ans
après les indépendances
ça fait plus de 70 ans parce que c'est
en 1945 que le franc cfa a été créé et
donc on ne devrait plus aujourd'hui
avoir un représentant du trésor public
ou de la banque de france qui siège dans
une banque centrale sur le continent
africain on n'a plus besoin de garanties
non plus parce que la seule fois que
l'afrique a eu besoin de faire
fonctionner la garantie que le trésor
public français est aujourd'hui la
banque centrale européenne propose c'est
de garantie n'a pas fonctionné et on a
dû dévaluer la monnaie dont je pense
qu'à partir de cet exemple et vu que les
réserves des pays africains sont au delà
de ce que la france demandent les pays
africains doivent simplement expliqué à
la france qu'elle n'est plus à sa place
dans le centre du jeu et que c'est entre
eux pays africains que cela devrait se
jouer je pense que ce courage politique
là quelqu'un devrait le prendre et
l'exprimé de façon très claire avant que
les populations ne s'en mêle et que ça
dégénère sur des haine anti français qui
sont injustifiés parce qu'en réalité ce
qu'on est en train de vouloir mettre
hors de là aux portes de nuire or 2 or 2
o 2 enfin ce qu'on voudrait mettre hors
d'état de nuire ce sont les dirigeants
c'est pas tous les français qui sont
concernés et si les dirigeants africains
on a à coeur de défendre des intérêts de
leur pays c'est elle de prendre ce débat
là une zone de libre échange économique
continentale est en train de se mettre
sur pied elle ne peut pas se faire avec
une monnaie comme le franc cfa les pays
d'afrique de l'ouest de la cdo sont en
train de réfléchir à une monnaie unique
qui devrait entrer en circulation en
2020 il ya peu de chances que ce soit en
2020 mais le projet est déjà en cours
donc il ya de fortes chances que ça
arrive donc je crois que toutes ces
initiatives la couplée au fait que les
crypto monnaie deviennent de véritables
enjeux aujourd'hui comme au venezuela
tout cela fait que le français fin et a
plus de débat à avoir dessus il faut
préparer la préf français fin et c'est
après francs cfa on n'a pas besoin de la
france pour on commence commencé à
tracer à en tracer les contours
est ce qu'elle est ce que veut je dirais
l'intelligentsia africaine qui
est interconnecté avec la france formé
par la france et par notre propre
intelligence ya n'est pas le bras armé
de la france où sein même de ce
territoire l'intelligentsia
africaine alors
dès les premiers à prendre des risques
allez on va prendre va se mouiller
complètement les indépendances
africaines déjà sondé indépendance tout
à fait factice parce que ceux qui se
sont battus pour les indépendances ont
presque tous été éliminés avant que les
pays du g20 devienne indépendant donc à
partir de là les de la donnée est fausse
et ceux qui voulaient l'indépendance ont
été supprimés ce qui n'en voulait pas se
sont comportés comme des préfets comme
des gouverneurs qui ont été placées là
pour défendre les intérêts autres que
ceux de leurs populations s'ils ne
voulaient pas l'indépendance et qu'il
préférait rester dans la suggestion et
qu'ils étaient là pour défendre des
intérêts et géopolitiques et économiques
qui étaient ceux de la puissance
coloniale et donc c'est ce qui a fait
que pendant les premières années
d'indépendance ils ont d'abord servi la
france puis la guerre froide aidant ils
ont servi le pan de l'otan qui était
celui de dire que quand on a un
communiste qui émergent ou quand qu'elle
peut être traité de communiste on peut
le suivre on peut s'en débarrasser on
peut supprimer sa vie ce sera normal
puisque c'est dans le cadre d'un combat
normal qui est celui de la lutte contre
le communisme et donc beaucoup de
dirigeants africains qui auraient pu
tracer [raclement de gorge]
poser les bases qu'elle de jeu prend
patrice lumumba seulement on aurait pu
citer thomas sankara mais nous en avons
déjà parlé aux camerounais ruben um
nyobè les exemples dans les pays
africains sont légions de dirigeants qui
ont été tués avant même les
indépendances et donc ce qui fait que
ceux qui avaient préparé le projet
d'indépendance il y avait un vrai projet
de société pour les pays n'ont pas pu
prendre les rênes du pays il est comparé
avec le handicap comme celui-là on ne
doit pas être surpris que les résultats
soient ce que nous avons aujourd'hui est
donc là aujourd'hui la foule est
impatiente les populations sur
impatiente mais il ya tellement de
choses à rectifier avant de remettre le
pays sur les rails que malheureusement
on n'en a plus pour très longtemps quoi
et j'espère que les immixtions
étrangères ne se feront plus aussi
fortement que c'est le cas aujourd'hui
est-ce
qu'on va avoir le temps de remettre sur
les rails ce continent avec le
réchauffement climatique qui accélère le
déplacement de populations sein même de
ce continent où est-ce que c'est pas
déjà trop tard dans c'est pas trop tard
je suis de nature optimiste et au delà
d'être optimiste je pense que les
africains eux mêmes se rendent compte
qu'ils ont la capacité d'agir c'est à
dire il ya une rengaine compas voit on
pas voir cette idée de dire nous avons
été victimes d'injustices dans
l'histoire on a subi l'esclavagé on a
subi la colonisation mais c'est un passé
qui est un peu lointain on a subi le néo
colonialisme aussi mais on peut se
reprendre en main et les dirigeants
africains les populations africaines ne
se trompe pas là dessus elle commence
aujourd'hui à travailler à préparer ce
que devrait être l'avenir du continent
et la place du continent sur la scène
internationale des partenariats comme
celui avec la chine voir avec la russie
et les pays des brics de façon plus
globale sont là pour montrer que si
jamais on avait la chance de faire
émerger des dirigeants suffisamment
conscience de ce qu'est la chose
publique
de ce qu'est l'intérêt général dans leur
pays on pourrait obtenir des résultats
cette conscience là est en train de
naître elle est portée par des
mouvements sociaux comme la lucha où il
y en a marre au sénégal et j'espère que
le soufflé ne retombera pas et qu'il
continuera de porter cette dynamique
pour que le continent africain et ses
ressortissants arrive enfin à reprendre
la place qui est la leur c'est à dire
une place d'égal à égal avec les deux
pays un pays une voix et et le droit au
bonheur comme tout le monde peut
l'espérer légitimement vous dites un
pays une voix mais l'afrique
n'a aucun représentant au sein du
conseil de sécurité malheureusement
au sein du fmi non plus je crois qu'ils
sont meilleurs seconds des sauts des
réformes qui ont été exigés par les
africains au
niveau de l'onu kofi annan avait été
porteur de ces flux déjà un feu kofi
annan sont payés atteint lui rendre
hommage le ghana il a porté cette idée
de réformer les nations unies de façon
générale et l'a porté l'idée de faire de
fixer des objectifs de développement
pour le millénaire qui devait concerner
pas que l'afrique mais la lutte contre
la pauvreté de façon générale ces
combats là aujourd'hui il continue
d'être portée avec moins d'intensité
avec moins de conviction mais je pense
que c'est aux africains finalement quoi
qu'il arrive de le faire s'ils ne
peuvent pas le faire individuellement
dans leur pays ils devraient au moins
avoir cette présence d'esprit et cette
volonté affirmée de monter que l'afrique
unie est encore capable d'étonner le
monde et de lui apporter quelque chose
une vraie valeur ajoutée c'est tout le
mal que je souhaite à la fois à nos
dirigeants et aux jeunes générations qui
sont en train de pousser pour apporter
leur contribution au développement de
l'afrique que vous expliquez que on
arrive à trouver des milliers de
milliards pour sauver les banques
européennes crise financière et qu'on
n'arrive pas à trouver une poignée de
billard pour se re a dit qu'est la faim
dans le monde et surtout la faim en
afrique je
crois que c'est un business qui peut
rapporter beaucoup de maintenir
certaines personnes dans la pauvreté je
vais prendre un exemple qui peut
paraître trivial mais qui en dit long
sur ce que cela peut être quand on parle
de la pauvreté sur le continent africain
beaucoup de gens ne croyaient plus avec
les années 90 que je vous décrivais lié
à l'austérité au consensus de washington
où on a expliqué que l'état devait se
désengager et laisser le marché faire la
loi tout le monde a eu l'impression que
les africains n'avaient plus les moyens
d'acheter n'était plus solvable on ne
pouvait plus rien faire en afrique les
compagnies de téléphonie mobile sont
venus battre cela à plate couture cette
idée a été éradiquée ici en france nous
consommons les crédits de communication
à crédit nous consommons là les données
mobile à crédit nous consommons même les
données de voix à crédit mais sur le
continent africain tout le monde paye
cash avant de communiquer ça dit que si
vous avez besoin d'appeler pour 5000
francs cfa par exemple vous devez avoir
5000 france les factures de téléphone
quand vous n'avez plus un franc cfa vous
ne pouvez plus appelé personne et ça
c'est plus de 90% de la population est
donc ce business la de la précarité fait
que aujourd'hui tout le monde est obligé
de payer cash et donc de parer au plus
pressé à chaque fois les chinois l'ont
compris quand vous voulez vous équiper
en équipant en produits manufacturés et
que vous n'avez pas lu - les moyens
d'acheter des produits fabriqués aux
états unis en allemagne ou en france
vous achetez un produit chinois qui
écoute peut être quatre fois moins cher
qu'ils aient dû peut-être moins
longtemps mais qui à haute portée et
donc ça c'est une réponse concrète à une
situation de fait c'est que les gens
n'ont peut-être pas les moyens d'acheter
très cher mais ils ont les moyens de
payer pour une certaine durée est de
renouveler ce paiement si j'ai une
chaussure pour deux semaines qui nous
coûte mille francs cfa je peux mettre de
côté mille francs cfa j'achèterai cette
chaussure peut-être deux fois dans le
mois mais ce sera ma portée or si elle
coûte 5000 francs et qu'elle peut durer
un an il est fort pause que je puisse
pas m'acheter de chaussures et donc du
coup il ya ce marché-là parallèle qui se
met sur pied le marché de la pauvreté
l'économie de la pauvreté qui profite à
beaucoup de monde les organisations non
gouvernementales
le business de du faux les faux
médicaments font partie également et
dont malheureusement tant qu'on n'est
pas protégés de cela par des règles du
commerce international plus équitable il
n'y a pas de réponse concrète on n'est
ce pas l'afrique dans un état de
précarité
pour mieux la contrôler oui parce
qu'après ça génère des conflits et des
conflits interethniques c'est un
business les biens la main c'est un vrai
business parce que l'industrie de
l'armement n'est pas une industrie
africaine c'est une industrie qui est
dans les pays du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies ces mêmes pays qui vendent
et qui estiment qu'ils peuvent aussi
défendre la paix dans le monde pour moi
c'est une vraie arnaque historique parce
que je veux bien qu'on explique à la
corée du nord et a beaucoup de pays
qu'ils doivent pas fabriquer deux bombes
atomiques à l'iran il ya d'autres pays
mais si l'exemple été donnée par les
cinq pays membres permanents du conseil
de sécurité
en arrêtant de fabriquer les armes ce
serait déjà un très bon signal mais nous
sommes dans une escalade qui ne s'arrête
pas et on explique à des personnes qui
comprennent que cette escalade est en
cours et qu'elle peut leur profiter
aussi qu'elles doivent cesser de
fabriquer des armes et que obsédant
vendre c'est assez compliqué à
comprendre pour quelqu'un qui veut
rester logique et donc les pays
africains aujourd'hui achète des armes
ou pour assurer leur sécurité mais les
mêmes qui leur vendent des armes pour
leur sécurité en vente pour les
déstabiliser également et donc c'est un
vrai business qui se met autour qui
génère beaucoup de choses quand on mène
la guerre chouvou comme on l'a fait en
libye par exemple et qu'on détruit
toutes vos infrastructures vous devez
les reconstruire et pour les oranges et
vous devez acheter dans les pays riches
les mêmes pays de l'otan qui vous ont
bombardé et donc vous payer à la fois
poète détruits et ensuite pour être
reconstruit c'est infernal et on ne s'en
sort pas c'est un cercle vicieux vous
parler de la libye mouammar kadhafi
avait été élu roi de l'afrique pour ses
projets d'irrigation de satellites et de
monnaie est ce que les africains ont un
sentiment de nostalgie de mouammar
kadhafi je pense que les livia sont les
premiers à avoir un sentiment de
nostalgie parce que quand on voit l'état
dans lequel la libye se trouve
aujourd'hui en état il
y a des raisons de nourrir des regrets
par rapport à ce qu'a été la période
kadhafi même si la liberté n'était pas
le point fort de ce régime là l'afrique
aussi à des raisons de nourrir des
regrets parce que quand on est passé de
l'organisation de l'unité africaine
créée en 1963 à l'union africaine à
syrte en 1999 c'est kadhafi qui a permis
que cette mutation se fasse
l'organisation de l'unité africaine
faisait face à des impayés très
important de la part des pays membres
qui auraient pu tuer l'organisation et
il a fallu que l'art doit soit effacée
par quelqu'un et cette ardoise a été
effacée par le colonel kadhafi le peuple
libyen et par le peuple libyen à travers
la signature de kadhafi le chèque qui là
qu'est la sortie donc de ce point de vue
oui il ya un vrai vide qu'ils aient
laissé l'homme était extravagant il a à
ce titre de roi des rois je pense pas
qu'il était indispensable mais il était
comme il est et il a fait ce qu'il a pu
sur le plan de la construction africaine
et je pense que si nous avions eu à la
fois une
union africaine suffisamment forte et
des dirigeants africains suffisamment
éclairé pour contenir les débordements
du colonel kadhafi il est fort à parier
que sa contribution aurait pu être utile
à la construction africaine parce que
cette idée qu'il avait de faire une
monnaie africaine n est pas si mauvaise
que cela on a un continent africain qui
ne s'intègrent pas le continent africain
celui qui commercent le moins entre lui
les pays africains ne se vende ni
n'achète pas grand chose entre eux leurs
140 vous une économie locale hawaii et
gilles otis et en afrique un sommet en
afrique pour les africains absolument ce
marché il en est où 2-0 pour l'instant
c'est zéro parce que si je produis du
cacao que vous êtes mon voisin que vous
produisez du cacao également je vais pas
vous vendre le même cacao vous n'en avez
pas besoin
nous sommes tous esclaves herti la côte
d'ivoire vend beaucoup de cacao ils
concurrencent du ghana qui en vend aussi
et tout cela tire les prix vers le bas
les économies sont extraverti et les
fluctuations sur le marché international
sont telles que cela ne peut pas être
bénéfique aux pays africains il s'agit
maintenant de faire en sorte non pas de
vivre en autarcie mais de vivre avec les
moyens dont on dispose d' arrêter
d'importer des choses qui coûtent cher
en devises en devises qu'on n'a pas
d'ailleurs et de produire des choses
dont on peut avoir besoin est de
structurer la production et la formation
pour que le relais soit pris pour que la
valeur créée profitent véritablement je
prends l'exemple d'un d'un paysan
gabonais
par exemple qui cultivent leur est dû du
cacao du du cacao des arachides peu
importe ce qu'il fait est ce qu'il a
besoin de monnaie pour vendre non parce
que la plupart du temps dans le passé ce
qu'il faisait c'était du troc il vivait
avec une économie démonétisé qui ne leur
donnait qui ne crée pas ce besoin de
devises pour les pays aujourd'hui on a
créé les devises on a créé et surtout
les économie extravertie qui font que
même l'argent qu'on gagne à l'extérieur
le peu qu'on gagne on s'endette pour
aller acheter davantage à l'extérieur et
du coup le paysan qui n'a pas d'argent
il est exclu du système économique et
commerciale et c'est laurent improductif
même si c'est lui qui soutient le groupe
de l'économie et les improductifs et ne
peut pas acheter il peut aider les
autres à acheter mais lui-même n'est pas
capable d'être dans ce rôle du donneur
d'ordre il vend son cacao mais ne peut
pas consommer de chocolat la tonne de
cacao qu'il vend ne lui permet pas
d'acheter 100 g de chocolat à quoi bon
c'est
une c'est une hérésie sur le plan
politique économique et je crois que la
première
justice qui devrait être réparée c'est
celle de faire que les pays africains
vivent avec les moyens qu'ils ont qu'ils
échangent entre eux qu'ils arrivent à
mutualiser ici même les entreprises le
font quand arrive la rentrée vous avez
des parents d'élèves qui se met souvent
ensemble pour acheter à bas prix parce
que ça permet de faire des économies
pourquoi les pays africains ne pourrait
pas le faire pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ne
pourraient pas monter des structures qui
traverse les états qu'ils soient
transnationales
et qui permettent de former des
universitaires de mettre à disposition
des structures hospitalières et d'autres
structures sociales qui profite à tout
le monde sans qu'on parle de deux
migrants africains venus du tchad ou du
cameroun pour envahir tel ou tel pays
moi je pense que ce chantier là il est
très important vous parlez des flux
migratoires en europe maintenant on voit
des africains dans la force de l'âge
débarqué sur l'écoutent appauvri
amaigri dans une situation sanitaire
dramatique ça
ne représente encore qu'un pouillème de
ce qui nous attend avec le réchauffement
climatique vous voyez la situation
comment évoluer la situation va
s'améliorer c'est à dire que l'afrique
va pouvoir garder sa force vive ou où ça
va empirer je
pense que l'afrique aujourd'hui fait
face à des enjeux parce que quand on
dirait que c'est tellement reste que
l'ouganda par exemple qui est aux
frontières de la rdc de la république
centrafricaine n'a pas les mêmes
préoccupations que le maroc ou l'afrique
du sud donc de ce point de vue les
réalités sont tellement diverse que
parlant
de pays qui envoient beaucoup de
migrants vers l'inde on a par exemple un
pays comme les pays en guerre de façon
générale quand il voyage s'est pas
directement vers l'europe qu'ils se
rendent je cite l ouganda tout à l'heure
pour une raison très simple c'est que
aujourd'hui il fait partie du trio de
pays qui accueille le plus de migrants
vous avez la turquie en tête vous avez
le liban est juste après celle où
grandin
l'ouganda qui accueille près d'un
million de migrants par an comparé
à ce que l'europe se plaint d'avoir à
ses portes je pense qu'il ya un gars
très important dans ces pays là on parle
pas de migrants c'est à dire qu'il n'ya
pas de déshumanisation comme nous
l'avons ici en europe on parle de
chiffres on ne parle plus de personnes
on sait pas si c'est des oiseaux qui
sont traités de migrants ou des
personnes pourtant il s'agit d'êtres
humains et ces personnes là ne partent
pas parce qu'elles n'ont pas plaisir à
vivre chez elle je connais pas grand
monde qui quitte sa maison de gaieté de
coeur pour aller ailleurs c'est parce
qu'elles ont des situations humaines
dans lesquelles elles sont en danger et
généralement apporter de l'aide à une
personne en danger en danger de mort des
fois et quelque chose d'humain et je
pense que l'europe comme les pays
africains qui sont traversés par ces
personnes qui ont qui sont obligés d
fois de partir de chez elle l'europe
devrait avoir devrait respecter ses
propres valeurs déjà et montrer un
exemple d'humanisme qu'elle a portée au
moment de la colonisation en disant
qu'elle allait prêcher des valeurs qui
devait être universel elles sont
tellement universel que l'europe
elle-même oublie aujourd'hui de se les
appliquer à elle-même et de les
appliquer à des personnes qui sont dans
le besoin de ressentir cette chaleur
humaine et ses valeurs humaines en
action quand elle quand elle appelle à
la volonté à la conscience à la bonne
conscience des européens je pense que
c'est dommage qu'ils aient cette
déshumanisation qui fait que des êtres
humains sont traités comme des chiffres
comme des déchets contrit comme des
chiens comme des chiens et ce serait
tout notre honneur de prendre notre part
à cette réunion
à nizas sion des êtres certains pays
africains malgré les moyens qui ne sont
pas nombreux le font déjà je pense que
l'europe peut le faire aussi et elle
doit le faire dans les prochaines années
davantage
je me rappelle plus le leader africain
qui avait dit
les occidentaux sont venus avec un la
bible nous avions les terrains c'était à
c'était djomo kenyatta c'était un
c'était au kenya et nous avons fermé les
yeux quand nous avons rouvert les yeux
il avait été amené à ouvrir les bibles
données [grognement] ou avec leur
religion en afrique la religion je
pense que c'est pas la religion qu'il
faut incriminer les gens aujourd'hui ont
besoin d'espoir d'espérance cet espoir
cette expérience ils ont l'impression
qu'ils peuvent les trouver dans la
religion c'est parce que rien d'autre ne
les fait rêver ce qu'on vous dit que
votre quotidien n'est pas joyeux et très
lourd à porter mais que dans une autre
vie vous serez au paradis cela vous fait
rêver cela vous permet d'avoir une fibre
une une lumière allumée qui vous
permettrait d'entretenir un certain
espoir mais quand en dehors de cela vous
n'avez rien pour vous raccrochez pour
accrocher votre espoir et et affronter
les difficultés de la vie c'est très
compliqué de vivre au quotidien même le
foot et le reste vous font rêver un
petit bout de temps seulement mais ce
temps là quand vous revenez chevaux il
expire assez rapidement et donc il faut
trouver d'autres moyens de rêver et
malheureusement au delà du rêve les
religions apporte aussi les guerres on a
vu en république centrafricaine même si
ce n'était pas le motif initial les gens
se sont affrontés en mettant en avant
leur religion certains en parlant de
christianisme d'autres d'islam on l'a vu
également en côte d'ivoire on le voit
sur de nombreux autres terrains c'est
dommage qu'ils aient cette récupération
sordide
de la religion pour servir des instincts
basiques de d'exploitation et
d'anéantissement de l'être humain mais
je pense que à la base la religion n'est
pas là pour remplir cette fonction tout
comme la politique mais et la religion
et la politique sont aujourd'hui devenus
des instruments à la fois d'assez de
d'assujettissement service man et même
d'asservissement des populations et donc
malheureusement il faut il faut
retourner à des valeurs plus humaine si
cela est possible encore avec
l'aide des religions ou sans leur aide
metz le libre arbitre de chacun qui
devrait s'exprimer là dessus parce que
vous avez une opinion concernant les
mouvements de radicalisation concernant
là je mets un truc qui met la négritude
les mouvements indigéniste et de l'autre
côté de la méditerranée des mouvements
radicaux
revendiquant
les valeurs gauloise trivialement est ce
que comme on fait pour réconcilier tout
ça on
apporte d'abord des solutions aux crises
l'afrique
est aujourd'hui traversée par des
tensions très fortes liées au tribalisme
liés à cette
volonté de certains pays de croire que
si des étrangers ne viennent pas chez
eux ils se porteront mieux si on les
expulse ça se passera mieux on l'a vu en
côte d'ivoire ça donnait la crise
préélectorale et post électorales de
2011 que nous avons vécu avec beaucoup
de peine ça se voit dans d'autres pays à
plus basse intensité est l'illustration
la plus dramatique de ce phénomène c'est
le génocide des tutsi au rwanda ce ne
sont pas des guerres parce que les gens
ne st pas ce ne sont pas des guerres
parce qu'il est impossible de faire
autrement ce sont des guerres parce que
l'instinct humain d'exploitation
de l'homme par l'homme a fait que on
utilise tous les moyens que l'on a sous
la main pour le faire et certains
s'accrochent à cela pour aller plus loin
estimé que l'homme blanc de façon
générale a fait tellement de mal à
l'homme noir que tout homme blanc qu'ils
verront devra payer pour ses ancêtres
qu'il n'a peut être pas connu et dont il
en tout cas pas responsable et donc je
crois qu'aujourd'hui la seule réponse
qu'on peut apporter sont d'abord des
réponses sociales avant d'être militaire
nous avons beaucoup militariser la
résolution des conflits les diplomates
n'ont plus de place les politiciens non
plus
instituteur les religieux sont de plus
en plus exploitée et je pense que c'est
quand on n'empêche à ces catégories
sociales de jouer leur rôle pour l'
équilibre au sein des groupes humains
que l'on est obligé d'utiliser la force
pour imposer des idées qui sont
peut-être noble mais qui ne seront
acceptés que temporairement le garder en
afghanistan a regardé au pakistan les
états unis sont intervenus pour imposer
ce qui semble être pour eux la norme
l'irak aussi a été victime de cela ça
n'a duré que le temps de leur présence
ça n'a duré que le temps d'une victoire
éphémère et les mauvais démons ont
repris le dessus dont je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une mauvaise idée
que de penser que quand il ya des idées
noires on doit utiliser la force pour
imposer ce qui nous semble être la norme
il faut utiliser le dialogue il faut
utiliser tous les éléments de dialogue
social pour que les uns et les autres se
mettent autour de la table et qu'on
gagne à la fois et la guerre et la paix
ce que vous connaissez quelqu'un qui
s'appelle qu'amis et ben oui qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
[soupir]
c'est [grognement]
difficile de juger mais je vais donner
mon point de vue kémi séba porte des
combats notamment sur le français fin j
team légitime tout à fait légitime mais
c'est pas parce qu'on a une réponse
légitime qu'on a une méthode acceptable
la
limite de l'exercice est là simplement
je pense que kémi séba remplit un vide
que les intellectuels ne prennent plus
la peine de remplir parce
qu'ils ne jouent pas leur rôle et que
tant qu'ils ne joueront pas leur rôle il
y aura non seulement des kémi séba mais
des pires que kémi séba et puis des
pires parce que le nationalisme et ce
sentiment de suprématie qu'on peut
recevoir positivement
ou négativement dans certaines sociétés
temps complète les égaux des gens avec
ces sentiments là on sait jamais ce qui
va sortir ce repli identitaire qu'il
prêche ya du repli identitaire également
mais je pense que ça ne produit rien de
bon même si au final de sauvegarde des
victimes oui oui oui vous me direz qu
aux états unis il a fallu un peu de ça
pour faire avancer la cause des noirs en
matière de droits civiques mais
comparaison n'est pas raison ce qui
s'est passé aux états unis ne sera pas
forcément vrai en france et ne sera pas
transposable sur le continent africain
non plus donc je pense que les
intellectuels africains tous
aujourd'hui comment des nous mais en
france vous en connaissez quelques-uns
alain mabanckou achille
mbembe en a une belle brochette
aujourd'hui d'intellectuels africains
ces intellectuels la devrait être plus
audible aujourd'hui qu'ils ne le sont il
devrait porter des projets de société et
surtout défendre des idées faire
diffuser des idées aussi
fortement que possible parce que leur
silence ou le expression pas
suffisamment forte laissent un champ un
champ vide que d'autres occupent avec
dédé pas toujours très louable et donc
c'est pas une critique c'est pas pour
disqualifier qui que ce soit mais je
crois qu'on peut avoir tout le monde il
a u du martin luther king aux états unis
et du mal comme aix c'est pas
incompatibles mais c'est parce qu'il ya
toutes ces forces là qu'on doit arriver
à apprécier la production des uns et des
autres en qualité plus qu'en quantité en
qualité et pourquoi pas en régularité
également ne démissionnons pas de nos
fonctions pense aux intellectuels ou pas
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que quand
on parle de l'afrique on voit la misère
on voit le désespoir et on s'en arrête
là et malheureusement ce qu'ils peuvent
allumer cette lumière là comme l'a fait
léopold sédar senghor ou comme l'a fait
aimé césaire en leur temps ces personnes
là ne sont pas très audible cl de
remplir le vide pour que les autres
viennent éventuellement leur apporter la
contradiction parce que c'est aussi ça
le rôle de l'intellectuel dans la
société c'était un agitateur d'idées ils
doivent remplir le rôle pour qu'on n'ait
pas à avoir un seul choix à effectuer
celui de kemi seba ou de quelqu'un
d'autre en
ce moment il ya beaucoup d'élections en
afrique ce qu'on voit toujours la main
de la françafrique ce qu'on voit
toujours la main de certains cabinets de
pub ce cabinet de communication est ce
que certaines entreprises françaises
sont toujours présents pour placer
leurs pantins on
ne sort pas indemne d'une domination
comme celle qu'a été la france 5 qui est
de la résilience souvent de la mauvaise
résidence le fera ses fans et une les
systèmes politiques extraverti actuels
en sont d'autres
la gestion des crises et des
manifestations publiques on est aussi
une autre illustration il ya
malheureusement encore beaucoup de gens
qui sans avoir besoin de la france parce
que sur le plan politique et militaire
la france est quand même beaucoup
diminué elle n'a plus sa superbe des
années 60 et donc elle n'a plus à
proprement [raclement de gorge] parler
les moyens d'intervenir de faire autant
pression qu'elle le faisait avant
cependant elle a des entreprises elle a
des dirigeants qui sont capables de de
positionner au de consolider certains
certains dirigeants pas toujours tes
comptes sociaux
et nous prenez [rires]
10 débit il s'en est vanté lundi qu'il
est encore au pouvoir c'est parce que la
force le lui a demandé c'est
malheureux a exprimé ainsi ce sont les
travers de la décolonisation et de la
françafrique tel que l'a conçu foccart
dans les années 60 pour permettre à la
france d'être une puissance présente au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies la
france n'a pas gagné la deuxième guerre
mondiale logiquement à ne devait pas
elle n'a pas fait partie de la
conférence de yalta elle n'avait aucun -
autre que celui de ses anciennes
puissances coloniales de se retrouver au
conseil permanent de sécurité des
nations unies portant il dit elle a une
puissance qui est que l a plus de 14 ou
15 pays sur le continent africain qui
dépend d'elle et qui vote de façon très
disciplinés en sa faveur au conseil de
sécurité ses réflexes là sont restés et
quand vous le gardez la manière dont les
élections se déroulent même dans un pays
comme la rdc qui n'a pas un passé
colonial liés à la france les dirigeants
les prétendants au poste de président
ont l'impression en passant par paris en
ayant la double main de paris en ayant
une photo avec emmanuel macron ou
n'importe quel autre président français
ça peut être un bon point auprès de
l'opinion assuré international ses
réflexes là sont des réflexes qu'il faut
aujourd'hui abolir mais malheureusement
ils continuent d'avoir cours ya
pas eu un procès avec boulouris si c'est
un plus qui font le
procès avec bolloré concerné
probablement son implication en guinée
conakry et l'aide que les entreprises de
bolloré notamment havas ont apporté au
candidat alpha condé devenu président
par la suite je pense que c'est un
mauvais procès parce que c'est pas sur
cet élément là qu'on va attaquer bolloré
les contraire que son entreprise fait
pour l'afrique c'est pas les éléments
les plus pertinents en revanche on peut
attaquer la manière dont les contrats
qu'ils s'y sont conduits il ya eu cet
accident et des cas au cameroun
sur la route entre yaoundé et douala la
capitale politique et la capitale
économique qui a fait des centaines de
morts j'aurais bien voulu avoir un
procès au fond bien sûr un accident
ferroviaire par une entreprise qui fait
particulièrement de bolloré bolloré
logistics j'aurais aimé qu'en france on
fasse un procès par rapport à cela
j'aurais aimé que sur la gestion des
ports quotidien bolloré la france si
elle tient véritablement à faire la
lumière sur les bonnes ou les mauvaises
pratiques de monsieur bolloré
s'intéresse à cela
j'aurais aimé que l'on latex sur
d'autres domaines beaucoup plus sensible
que celui de ce dossier où ce sont des
facturations entre deux entreprises
appartenant à la même entité des
contrats commerciaux qui ne regarde pas
l'état français j'aurais aimé qu'ils
interviennent là dessus malheureusement
ils sont partis sur l'élément le moins
pertinent et sur lequel bolloré leur
fournira probablement des réponses
suffisamment acceptable par le doigt
pour ne pas être condamné la
corruption en afrique ça existe toujours
beaucoup beaucoup moins qu'en france que
de nom disons que les dirigeants
africains disent c'est
pas pour cautionner ou pas ce qu'ils
disent ils disent qu'ils ont été à
l'école de la france et des dirigeants
français et que le mot corruption dans
certaines langues n'existe même pas
c'est pas parce qu'un mot n'existe pas
que le phénomène n'existe pas on va pas
se mentir on va pas jouer sur les mots
mais le fait est que aujourd'hui
sur le continent la corruption devient
criminelle pour une raison simple c'est
que quand vous détourner de l'argent qui
devait servir à construire une école à
construire des hôpitaux à permettre la
prise en charge de certaines personnes
nécessiteuses en matière de soins et qui
n'ont pas les moyens de les payer vous
les condamnés à mort et donc cette
corruption la même si elle n'est pas
très importante elle a des résultats
catastrophiques pour des gens elle à des
résultats dramatiques pour une société
et je pense que c'est pour cette raison
que en afrique dans les pays
sous-développés plus qu'ailleurs
la corruption est un mal à combattre
avec la dernière énergie les africains
ne sont pas pires que les autres ils
sont pas meilleurs non plus mais le fait
est que quand ça produit autant de
dégâts il faut s'arrêter deux grandes
faire le bilan et trouver des solutions
pour que ce phénomène qui fait autant de
mal ne prospère pas si j'ai un contre
mais moi c'est dans quel pays qui est un
proverbe qui dit méfie-toi du groupe
concernant
la corruption je
ne sais pas ce que celui qui corrompu et
en jouant en général beaucoup plus en
cher que les autres vous n'avez pas
remarqué ce fait le jeu de la wii et
même dans les dessins de presse en a
fait vous verrez que le corrompu où le
dirigeant politique quand ils arrivent
au pouvoir ils là délà des mensurations
normales et au bout de six mois voire un
peu moins d'ailleurs il prend beaucoup
de gras petite
parenthèse est-ce que vous avez des
poètes ou des livres avec des racines
africaines à nous conseiller a conseillé
à notre communauté vous savez je vous
conseillerais des lectures qui sait en
10 grand pansement technologie nous
mêmes même des penseurs contemporains
qui ne sont pas forcément dans je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de livres aujourd'hui
qu'on peut conseiller il ya une dame
comme aminata dramane traoré pour
laquelle j'ai beaucoup d'estimé qui fait
un vrai travail à la fois de
conscientisation et de restructuration
du débat pour le recentrer parce que il
ya une chose aujourd'hui qui est une
vraie dérive est une vraie plaie sur le
continent africain c'est que l'on a
l'impression que il ya que la politique
pour changer l'avenir des africains il
ya que des élections pour changer la vie
des africains et le fait d'avoir donné
cette impression fait que quand on est
élu président en afrique c'est presque
comme si on avait été condamné à mort
dès le jour de son élection parce qu'on
n'a pas de réponse sociale véritable a
apporté aux gens on n'a pas toujours les
soutiens internationaux pour le fer et
la plupart du temps on applique des
programmes qui sont conçus de
l'extérieur personne a démantelé par
exemple ce consensus de washington dont
on parlait tout à l'heure
qui disait que l'état doit se désengager
il doit dépasser de moins en moins faire
des partenariats public privé pour que
ce soit les entreprises privées qui
investissent y compris dans les domaines
sociaux se délester de l'investissement
souvent cela s'accompagne aussi d'une
dette intérieure très importante qui
n'est pas toujours réglé et je pense que
la première priorité dans ce genre de
combat et ses nattes à traoré qui le
rappelle très bien c'est d'arrêter avec
l'austérité parce que moins les gens
dépensent moins il ya d'argent et plus
voulait taxer alors qu'ils n'ont pas
d'argent moins vous êtes certain d'avoir
votre argent et donc vous ajoutez à ça
les barrières douanières qui sont de
plus en plus à fait c'est le débat doit
porter sur cela sur la pauvreté et
s'agit pas juste de dire qu'on va
permettre aux africains d'avoir plus de
deux dollars par jour pour vivre il
s'agit aussi de créer les conditions
pour qu'il ne soit pas fragiliser dans
les entreprises qui le met sur pied que
ce soit sur le plan agricole ou ailleurs
parce que la concurrence de
l'agriculture européenne est là la
concurrence de l'agriculture américaine
est là qui sont tout sponsorisé alors
que les agriculteurs africains ne
bénéficient pas de ce même soutien de la
part de leur état et je crois que tant
qu'on restera dans des schémas qui sont
des camisoles de force imposée aux pays
africains on ne s'en sortira pas et donc
je conseille vivement aminata dramane
traoré ne serait ce que pour cette
raison là on peut être les
poètes j'en lis pas beaucoup il
y en a quelques-uns il ya eu tikrit au
thème si au congo il ya il ya de
nombreux autres poètes qui font du très
bon travail mais c'est vrai que la
poésie n'est pas l'élément n'est pas le
le genre littéraire qui me fascine le
plus mais lisons lisons quelques-uns des
écrivains qui parlent du quotidien
actuel des africains qui gagne à être
connu je reviens juste vous êtes pour ou
contre le partenariat public friand
prévu je ne suis pas contre les
partenaires publics privés ce que je
disais que oui je suis pour mais il ne
faut pas que ce soit la règle il faut
que l'état joue son rôle et que les
partenaires privés qui veulent
accompagner l'état vienne l'accompagner
mais ne lui impose pas
de pratiquer des prix qui ne permettront
pas si je vous vends pas la france à ne
pas trouver un partenaire plus prévu on
se fait avoir en compte l'enjeu c'est
sûr et en afrique d'imaginer donc le
temps que cela peut représenter parce
que sur les autoroutes en france j'ai
bien compris que c'était un jeu de dupes
et qu'il profiter davantage aux
entreprises concessionnaires qui gère
ces autoroutes là en afrique imaginez
vous que ça va jusqu'à la gestion de
l'eau de l'électricité jusqu'à
enfin il ya tellement de secteurs dans
lesquels l'état devrait être souverain
que je ne comprends pas pourquoi il
laisse la priorité aux investisseurs qui
ne font pas du bénévolat qui ne sont pas
là pour assurer la sécurité sociale ddd
ressorti son char en venir il soit là
pour gagner de l'argent pour des fonds
d'investissements des fonds de pension
qui sont d'ailleurs pas du tout en
afrique je reviens sur une question
d'internet est ce que l' idéologie
tiers-mondiste anti impérialiste est
elle encore vivante en afrique elle est
portée par déjà encore aminata traoré
elle est portée par de nombreuses autres
personnalités dont les voix ne sont pas
suffisamment entendu ne sont pas
suffisamment entendu aller à l'extérieur
et même à l'intérieur parce que quand
aujourd'hui une crise éclate
que ce soit en côte d'ivoire que ce soit
au gabon que ce soit au congo ou au
soudan voire en ethiopie qui aujourd'hui
l'une des économies les plus prospères
du continent africain l'idée c'est pas
d'analyser les raisons et de trouver des
réponses concrètes c'est de dire il ya
des dirigeants politiques qui ont
impliqué des règles qui n'était pas
celle qu'on leur demandait souvent et je
vais donner l'impression de défendre ses
dirigeants mais quand vous avez 15 pays
qui vous aident à financer votre
économie et qui vous demande de produire
des rapports mensuels là dessus où
passez souvent plus de temps à produire
des rapports pour expliquer ce que vous
avez fait qu appliquer le programme où
le projet de société pour lequel vous
avez été élu et je crois que toutes ces
choses là sont aujourd'hui tellement
sérieuse que l'afrique doit arrêter avec
l'aide elle doit arrêter avec cette aide
publique au développement qui est devenu
un élément d'assujettissement des pays
pour s'investir dans ce qu'elle sait
faire dans ce qu'elle peut faire par
elle-même avant de solliciter l'aide
extérieure qu'elle soit chinoise
européenne et américaine ce que vous
connaissez la monuc os x la mission des
nations unies est ce que vous avez
entendu parler des bébés monuc oui mais
nous on dire la monuc qui est devenue la
monusco exactement oui c'est l'une des
dérives de de ce système des nations
unies qui envoient des casques bleus
pour maintenir la paix dans les endroits
où la paix n'existe pas parce que pour
faire du maintien de la paix faut qu'il
y ait de la paix or il arrive pour faire
du maintien de la paix en situation de
guerre et la plupart du temps vu qu'ils
n'ont pas suffisamment de repères ou de
formation pour rempli correctement leur
rôle on part sur des dérives je prends
juste le cas la rdc pour la monusco que
vous citez les forces sont souvent
stationné à kinshasa et quand vous
connaissez la grandeur de la république
démocratique du congo où il faut souvent
deux voire trois heures pour parcourir
le pays par avion c'est indécent les
guerres se passe dans l'est du pays
c'est-à-dire à trois heures de kinshasa
et malheureusement les troupes sont
stationnés la plupart du temps à
kinshasa et donc ça crée une inflation
parce que les moyens avec lesquels ces
casques bleus arrivent sont telles que
ils peuvent avoir des moyens de pression
pour monnayer les services qu'ils
rendent ou l'aide qu'ils apportent
auprès de petites filles auprès de
prostituées auprès de nombreuses autres
personnes et ces cas-là de dérive ne
s'était pas bousiller c'était carrément
pris de chance oui des fois et il
monnaye aussi mais je veux dire quand
vous prenez par exemple le loyer le prix
du loyer à kinshasa il est passé du
simple au quintuple très rapidement avec
l'installation des forces de des nations
unies parce qu'ils ont les moyens de
payer et donc vous arrivez vous êtes
dans une économie qui vit parce que on
importe beaucoup de choses pour ce
contingent là au mali vous avez la même
question tout est importé et les moyens
sont là pour permettre que quand on veut
faire la fête on ait les moyens de faire
la fête et malheureusement la mission
n'est pas accomplie avant avant que la
fête soit faite et c'est ça qui est la
grosse d yves au sein de ce système des
nations unies qui doit être réformé mais
qui ne l'est toujours pas on va passer à
quelques questions internet brut alors
première à ce que les aides humanitaires
sont hélas marchés financiers mais vous
y avaient déjà répondu je crois que oui
oui je crois que les
organisations non gouvernementales
apporte
une aide qui peut être considérable
quand on est dans les pays dans des
zones surtout où les gouvernements des
pays concernés ne peuvent pas intervenir
mais au bout d'un certain temps on ne
doit pas s'installer dans un business de
la charité et ça devient business quand
ça devient long il faut travailler en
harmonie avec les pays travaillent avec
l' oms mais l'essai que ce soit l'état
qui trace les grandes lignes et surtout
ne pas créer de dépendance vis-à-vis des
ong
autre question concernant l'afrique du
sud tout en style de ce qu'il se passe
en afrique du sud julius malema la place
de l'homme blanc en afrique du sud la
place de l'agriculture le
problème des terres c'est la réforme les
afrikaners qui sont expulsés les anciens
afrikaner expulsés ils sont sud
africains moi je crois qu'ils sont
d'abord sud africain mais que au delà
d'être sud-africain il ya un problème
d'accaparement des terres qui n'a pas
été résolu pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui ce serait illégitime de
dire que quand on m'a volé quelque chose
on doit me le rendre sur les biens
culturels il y à une discussion il y à
une réflexion qui commence à être mené
pour que les propriétaires légitimes de
rentrer en possession de leurs biens je
n'ai pas l'impression que cela choque
qui que ce soit et donc si on peut le
faire avec les biens culturels là ce
sont des bien palpable concret c'est des
terres on sait à qui elle appartenait et
je ne comprends pas que cela choque
qu'on demande de rendre les terres leurs
propriétaires
quitte à ce que ce soit une
reconnaissance simplement pour dire ses
terres vous appartenez on vous paiera un
bail par rapport à ce qu'on en fait on
va vous dédommager pour l'exploitation
qui en a été fait jusqu'à présent et on
vous paiera un bail de façon régulière
sur la manière dont on gérera tous là
mais je pense que quand on a volé en
produits et qu'on passe en justice on ne
peut pas dire que c'est anormal
être entendu et peut être sanctionné
pour le vol qu'on a effectués lyon est
ce qu est ce que c est exportable en
israël ce modèle là c'est exportable à
tous les pays je pense que les élèves ne
sont pas des sous-hommes ou des
surhommes ce sont des sommes tout
simplement et donc la justice qui
s'applique aux hommes doit s'appliquer à
la fois aux sud africains et océaniens
également alors une question qu'on style
que l'afrique va proposer un autre
modèle que celui des occidentaux et si
oui en quoi sera-t-il différent
le modèle que la fée peut proposer c'est
déjà celui de l'écologie vous savez que
parmi les deux poumons de la planète
on en a un qui se trouvent en afrique
centrale c'est le bassin du congo c'est
déjà une contribution très forte à
l'écologie sur la planète la deuxième
contribution c'est que l'afrique
aujourd'hui est une haine est un
continent en croissance permanente
il
suffit juste que ces énergies soient
bien canalisée pour que l'afrique
apporte à la planète au delà de ce
qu'elle apportera à ses ressortissants
cet élément qui fait que la
mondialisation est à la fois au rendez
vous du donner mais aussi à nouveau dû
recevoir et que les africaines
arriveront pas les mains vides je suis
convaincu qu'ils le feront et même si
j'ai pas d'élément palpable la sous la
main pour vous le dire je sais que les
énergies sont mis en place pour cela des
pays sont en train de construire ses
modèles le kenya le
rwanda et bien d'autres pays l'ethiopie
sont en train aujourd'hui de montrer que
on n'est pas obligé d'être complètement
occidentalisée pour réussir et même
l'union africaine nécessaire
de ne pas être occidentalisée pour
réussir même survivre non non je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas faire un
retour en arrière complet on va pas
s'empêcher d'utiliser internet on va pas
s'empêcher de prendre l'avion on va pas
s'empêcher de faire des transferts
bancaires mais on peut simplement
remettre beaucoup plus d'humains que de
chiffres que de dématérialiser dans ses
rapports là il faut que ça serve l'homme
aujourd'hui ça sert les profits ça sert
les profit d'un petit nombre qui
s'enrichit de plus en plus au détriment
de la grande majorité vous parliez
d'internet
on sait que l'afrique est un pays ultra
connectés par les téléphones mobiles
quand on voit une jeunesse africaine
exposés aux dérives des de la publicité
occidental où tout le monde est riche
tout le monde roule en mercedes on
sort tous avec des avions de chasse et
tout va bien est ce que cette idéologie
capitalistique
n'est pas en train de contaminer votre
propre camp jeudi vote jeudi la jeune
génération africain n'est pas en train
de contaminer cette jeune génération et
n'est pas en train de guider l'afrique
vers ces mêmes dérives surconsommation
de surproduction ce
n'est pas le bien qu'ils aient ce n'est
pas le bien en tant que biens matériels
qui est le problème c'est l'usagé que
l'on en fait c'est comme si on vous
expliquait que l'atom est mauvais
l'atome en lui-même n'est pas mauvais
c'est l'usagé qu'on en fait si on fait
une bombe atomique c'est dangereux à la
fois pour son fabricant et pour ceux qui
vont probablement la recevoir mais si on
utilise pour des raisons médicales pour
soigner des gens ça peut être utile et
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que ces
biens matériels cet argent ces moyens
technologiques ne sont pas mis au
service de l'humanité ils sont utilisés
pour asservir ils sont utilisés pour
flatter les égos et c'est là que le
problème se pose et pense que si
l'afrique définissait son concurrent
corpus de valeurs et s'en tenait à ce
corpus ça
se passerait mieux aujourd'hui on veut
réguler partout vous remarquerez que
chaque fois qu'il ya des élections dans
les pays africains il ya une coupure
d'internet pendant la période que dure
ou la proclamation des résultats où le
vote et ça ça
signifie qu'il comprenne qu'il ya un
moyen de contrôle est peut-être mal mais
ils le font et si on pouvait définir
encore plus de valeur qui fasse que tout
cela se fasse dans le sens de l'intérêt
général dans le sens de l'humain ce
serait mieux mais malheureusement pour
ça faut déjà qu'ils aient une entente
suffisante sur ce que sont les valeurs
et sur ce que sont les orientations
idéologiques et social
de chacune des sociétés concernées autre
question internet à caen soulèvement du
peuple dans les pays africains que
manque il selon vous il ya déjà eu des
soulèvements ne faisons pas encore s'il
n'y a pas eu de mouvement on l'a vu au
burkina faso avec blaise compaore qui a
dû partir on l'a vu au zimbabwé avec la
révolution du palais le traitement
comment blaise compaoré le traître oui
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de données
précises sur le fait que ce soit lui ou
pas qui est faible thomas sankara mais
un faisceau de ya
un faisceau de présomptions qui
convergent quand même beaucoup vers lui
et qui fait que certains l'accusent
d'avoir tué son ami et complice pourtant
celui qui l'avait fait sortir de prison
parce qu'il est en prison quand la
révolution a eu lieu pour que thomas
sankara sorte de prison à l'époque c'est
blaise compaore qui avait porté les
troubles qui ont fait le coup des terres
et ont permis à thomas sankara dû sortir
mais c'est également lui qui accusait de
l'avoir tué et d'avoir donc arrêter le
projet politique qui était le sien en
direction du burkina faso aux
questions internet coûte des enjeux
stratégiques des terres rares encore peu
trop présenté au public pour
l'interrogation l'enjeu
des terres rares c'est qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup
de pays ont besoin de terres pour
l'agriculture pour nourrir leurs
populations étaient rares dans les
composants des téléphones portables et
ainsi de suite ah oui pardon je t'ai
partie sur terre oui en république
démocratique du congo qui est le
principal fournisseur de ceux de ce
métal de
ces métaux de tous ces métaux la rdc est
un scandale géologique comme disait
comme disait quelqu'un
fait est que l'exploitation que
subissent les mineurs et ce n'est pas
mineur juste parce qu'ils descendent
dans les mines c'est que ce sont souvent
des enfants qui vont l'exploitation que
subissent ces personnes est
insupportable
elle est inhumaine et à côté de cela
vous avez des zones de guerre parce que
c'est souvent en zone de guerre que ça
se passe vous prenez le qui vous lit
tout et les deux kivu d'ailleurs tout ce
qui s'y passe en termes de viol en
termes de de supplice imposer aux gens
en termes de barbarie humaine tout cela
est insupportable mais les entreprises
qui bénéficient des
fruits de cette violence là ne respecte
aucun code d'éthique on a imposé cela
aux fabricants de textile pourquoi ne
pourrait-on pas l'imposer aux fabricants
d'avions
ou aux fabricants de téléphones
portables pour que l'on sache au moins
et même par rapport aux diamants au
diamant 200 200 il ya des règles qui ont
été établies
malheureusement sur la rdc qui subit la
même chose par rapport à ces métaux il
n'y a malheureusement pas de règles et
je crois que la conscience universelle
devrait
se pencher sur cette question et l'on
devrait avoir les mêmes exigences mais
la vie de ces industries que pour les
autres industries en question internet
que je vais essayer de former un petit
peu quel regard des populations locales
sur le futur de la viabilité climatiques
du continent est ce que laisse que les
populations locales sont conscientes
qu'une climatiquement parlons ça part en
sucette je
vais prendre deux là parce qu'ils sont
en train de migrer parce qu'il n'arrive
plus à manger à cause des familles d'un
site huit d'entre eux les gens sont
tellement préoccupés par les
contingences du quotidien que la plupart
du temps et ne se projette pas au-delà
de 3 mois 6 mois ou ne se préoccupe pas
des questions d'écologie prenez des
populations pygmées par exemple qui sont
dans la forêt équatoriale d'afrique
centrale vous leur expliquer les enjeux
écologiques ils vous diront que c'est
leur quotidien pour eux c'est important
mais quand on vend ses concessions là
pour que des entreprises viennent
acheter du bois exploité du bois et le
vendre à l'extérieur personne ne tienne
compte de cet habitat et des conditions
de vider des pics mais ne tient compte
des animaux qui vivent dans cette espèce
et de l'équilibré que tout cela doit
produire donc ce ne sont pas les
populations qui ont ce problème et quand
vous êtes en situation de guerre comme
c'est le cas dans la plupart des pays où
on coupe du bois de façon anarchique
vous ne vous posez pas à cette question
vous avez besoin de faire du feu vous
avez besoin de faire cuire vos repas et
pour vous alimentez alimenter vos
enfants c'est la dernière de vos
préoccupations
mais je pense que tout cela ne peut être
réglée que si on règle déjà les
problèmes de base qui sont posées en
termes d'austérité en termes d'économie
et en termes de de vie sociale
simplement au sein des pays parce que
prenez une maladie comme ebola c'est une
maladie de la honte c'est
une endémie qui subsistent parce que les
gens mangent de la viande de brousse de
la viande de brousse contaminés par les
chauves-souris et quand vous êtes en
guerre quand vous êtes dans un pays qui
fait face à des conflits que vous enfui
dans dans la forêt vous ne pouvez manger
que de la viande de brousse est donc en
mangeant de la viande de brousse vous
avez une chance sur deux de tomber sur
de la viande qui était infesté par les
chauves-souris et donc d'attraper bola
donc la préoccupation est là mais les
gens n'ont pas n'ont pas toujours
forcément le choix quant à savoir s'ils
vont consommer ou s'ils vont préserver
l'environnement que
vous prévu sur le journalisme en afrique
sur internet le journalisme en afrique
moi je pense qu'il faut pas aussi pourri
que sous lequel d'outreau nantes il a
les mêmes problèmes mais à une échelle
plus grande c'est que déjà les
promoteurs de médias n'ont pas forcément
beaucoup d'argent les populations ne
crois pas beaucoup à ce qui est écrit
parce qu'ils savent que c'est orienter
et les journalistes sont eux-mêmes
soumis à des astreintes qui font que des
fois ils sont très peu regardants de la
charte de munich ou de la déontologie
journalistique et du coup ça ouvre la
porte et les fenêtres à toutes les
dérives mais au-delà de tout cela je
crois qu'aujourd'hui on a quand même un
journalisme de qualité sur le continent
africain et le monde
ce qui est le cas d un journalisme de
qualité en afrique on
pourrait citer plusieurs prenez des
journaux comme le génie point cornes
prenait des journaux comme les
noms ne me reviennent pas à mettre des
journaux nigérians ou ou aux kenyans qui
sont aujourd'hui des journaux auto
suffisant parce qu'ils sont capables de
trouver leur public il en existe encore
mais malheureusement ce sont les
exceptions qui confirment qu' il ya une
véritable crise de l'industrie de la
presse sur le continent africain africa
numéro un qui était le fleuron de la
radio panafricaine est aujourd'hui en
très grande difficulté c'est une radio
qui va peut-être fermer mais c'était une
radio qui faisait la fierté des
africains et qu'il y avait une
couverture continental vous prenez les
chaînes de télévision elle vivote
pratiquement pour celles qui sont
panafricaine que ce soit je vais en
citer quelques unes pour que soient
télésud que ce soit vox afrique que ce
soit africable que ce soit africa 24 ou
d'autres encore c'est celle là ont du
mal à avoir un modèle économique qui les
met à l'abri des contingences qui sont
celles des petites chaînes à diffusion
nationale ou régionale je pense que le
gros problème aujourd'hui c'est que le
modèle économique et surtout la capacité
pour les médias d'avoir des sociétés
viable sur la durée cette question n'a
pas encore été réglé les aides qui sont
apportées aux sociétés de presse et aux
journalistes sont des aides qui les
contraignent en quelque sorte d'être les
bons élèves des gouvernements et ça
c'est pas la solution qu'on va apporter
ce sont des pansements sur des sur des
bouts de bois qui ne permettront pas
d'aller loin et je pense que le modèle
doit être complètement repensée pour
faire que les entreprises de presse soit
d'abord des entreprises et que les
journalistes soient des salariés comme
tous les autres protégés par la loi est
capable de vivre de leur art le dollar
sql france 24 et la fp sont toujours mal
perçue en afrique à ce que la fp
toujours considéré comme l' agence
france-presse grande est ce que france
24 est toujours considéré que la voix du
maître de paris ça
dépend des moments il ya des moments où
quand les dirigeants africains arrivent
en france ils sont bien contents d'avoir
une couverture de la fp ou de france 24
voire de vérifie il ya des moments en
période de crise où ils sont très
mécontents avec le traitement que leur
réserve des chaînes comme la fp ou
france un catch et d'autres encore parce
que c'est pas ce ne sont pas les seuls
qui sont concernés par cette perception
souvent négatives dans
les années 70 il ya eu un africain
à la tête de l'unesco mme akhtar bo qui
avait demandé qu'on revoie le nouvel
qu'on bâtisse un nouvel ordre mondial de
l'information de la communication parce
qu'il estimait que l'image qui était
donnée de l'afrique par les grands
médias internationaux
c'est à dire les médias des cinq pays
les plus puissants de la planète
n'étaient pas toujours une bonne image
que c'était une image à sens unique où
on n'avait que les guerres les maladies
les crises et tout ce qui peut être
négatif et que cela faisait souvent
partir fuir les investisseurs qui
avaient souvent qui se renseigner avant
d'aller investir en afrique ce n'est pas
faux mais à côté de cela quand on a
l'impression d'être mal servi par les
autres qu'est ce qui nous empêche de
bâtir un modèle économique est une
entreprise de presse suffisamment fortes
pour restaurer l'équilibré je pense que
la critique est fondée mais que à côté
de la critique il faut une action pour
répondre à cette situation et que cette
réponse tarde à arriver de la part des
africains est-ce que les excuses
africains sont conscients que la
france a des grandes oreilles sur leur
connexion internet avec les câbles sous
marins et à ce que vous avez un oeuf un
avis sur africa coast to europe le cap
chemin avec comment j'avais
d'inconscience yom de 19 opérateurs
c'est le problème des data qui est très
important les données aujourd'hui voyage
beaucoup et elles voyagent souvent vers
les grands opérateurs des gaffes qui
sens de la grandeur de la france aussi
un la géopolitique des câbles et on se
demande bien pourquoi tous les cas bleus
partent de la france info oui oui parce
qu'avant même pour appeler d'une ville à
une autre sur le continent africain ont
passé par la france là il n'y avait pas
un co internet on passait déjà par la
france aujourd'hui les grands opérateurs
prennent le contrôle sur le terrain mais
ils prennent le contrôle parce que il ya
une entreprise sud-africaine en
téléphonie mobile qui existe qui
s'appelle indienne qui a investi dans de
nombreux pays africains et de nombreux
opérateurs qui se bousculent aux portes
l'afrique aujourd'hui n'est plus un no
man's land c'est un terrain qui est
énormément investi par les grandes
entreprises tant française que allemande
vietnamienne
chinoises brésiliennes dont c'est pas
que la france qui est concerné par cela
mais le problème c'est que l'afrique n'a
pas encore saisi l'importance qu'il ya
deux pouvoir à la fois assurer la
sécurité des personnes et des biens mais
également la sécurité des données et des
données informatiques qui se balade
aujourd'hui partout
google en profite yahoo en profit
d'autres opérateurs en profitent il
faudrait songer à avoir des centres sur
le continent africain qui permettent de
centraliser cela est de mettre un peu
d'ordre dans la manière dont les données
circulent pas ce que ça va au ferry
peut-être mais ya aujourd'hui dans
certains gouvernements des ministres qui
fonctionnent avec des boîtes mails qui
ne sont pas des boîtes gouvernement tels
qu'ils sont des boîtes à yahoo ou google
ou en d'autres et donc qui met en danger
même la sécurité de leur pays en
utilisant des choses qui pour eux
semblent normales sur le plan privé mais
qui ne sont pas normal du tout parce
qu'ils sont à la tête au delà de leur
propre personne de données de et et
d'éléments qui concerne la vie d'une
nation devra sûrement la même chose en
france un rôle
du fmi en afrique pour l'interrogation
que sont internet
le rôle du fmi cette ceni l'afrique y
est plus nuancé que cela le fmi a fait
beaucoup de mal à l'afrique mais il a
fait beaucoup de mal à l'afrique parce
que les dirigeants africains ont permis
que cela se passe ainsi la mauvaise
gestion du bien public de l'argent
public qui a été effectué avec tous les
éléphants blancs qu'on a eues entre les
années 60 et les années 80 a contribué à
appauvrir le continent africain a
instauré une certaine gabégie que le fmi
a constaté simplement et donc en
arrivant à l'appel des pays africains il
a une histoire remède de cheval qui a
été plus dure que la crise elle-même que
subissaient ces pays là et donc on ne
peut pas dire que le médecin a tué un
patient qui était déjà malade certes il
a une responsabilité très forte mais
cette responsabilité
elle est due au fait que le malade
lui-même s'est empoisonné avoir de faire
appel au médecin et donc à partir de là
certes on doit être dur avec le fmi qui
n'a pas eu une politique qui aurait dû
au moins reconnaître la faute qui a été
la sienne dans la gestion des crises
économiques sur le continent africain
est donc trouver un élément de
réparation mais on ne peut pas lui
imputer toute la responsabilité de ce
qui se passe sur le continent africain
non
comment voyez-vous la démographie en
afrique comment le continent perçoit les
choses il
n'y a pas une lecture unique vous prenez
vous prenez le nigeria il va être le
troisième pays le plus peuplé du monde
dans moins de 30 ans il sera le
troisième appelé à la chine et l'inde
c'est pas qu'un problème c'est
aujourd'hui un atout parce que quand
vous avez le marché vous êtes également
intéressant et c'est d'abord un intérêt
pour les africains eux mêmes cela dit ça
montre que quand vous êtes béninois est
voisin du nigeria vous pouvez faire des
affaires avec le nigeria vous avez un
marché de 500 millions de personnes qui
s'ouvre à vos jeux c'est pas une façon
un peu anciennes de concevoir l'économie
la
démographie sur une fonction
exponentielle en termes de marché
je le dis parce que c'est l'élément le
plus palpable que nous avons aujourd'hui
les pays d'afrique en commerce mais le
problème c'est qu'ils ne connaissent pas
entre eux ils commercent avec
l'extérieur et ils commercent de façon
indépendante
il faut aujourd'hui instaurant un cercle
vertueux qui fasse que les africains
commercent entre eux et si l'afrique à
la puissance démographique pour être
autonomes comme le fait la chine comme
le font les états unis aujourd'hui je ne
pense pas que ce soit un élément
affaiblissant au contraire c'est un
élément structurant pour les économies
africaines qui pourrait ainsi envisager
leur développement sans être à 100 est
exposé à des aléas extérieurs plus
importante que les aléas intérieur qui
sont les éléments les plus pertinents de
mon point de vue en matière
d'appréciation économique vous arrivez à
la fin de notre interview on s'est
rencontré au festival international du
journalisme organisé par le monde à
couthures-sur-garonne que nous avons
d'ailleurs renommé beuvry sur garonne
c'est très intéressant devant les
journalistes après après 20h30 là bas on
a fait quelques images très croustillant
ne sont pas ceux petite dédicace ou au
monde ils vont pas être déçus du voyage
et quand je ne suis pas dans les images
parce que c'est très bien voilà vous
[rires]
avez pas vu boire beaucoup d'alcool
l'avait d'ailleurs vous connaissiez
avant d'ailleurs ou pas du tout avec le
monde non avec un single you oui oui
j'ai regardé plusieurs interviews de
fink view parce que je les trouvais très
intéressante je voulais dit d'ailleurs
je trouve que c'est très positif une
initiative comme celle là parce que ça
devient de plus en plus rare aujourd'hui
en france de parler d'afrique et d'avoir
du temps pour le faire donc je trouve
que c'est à la fois courage et généreux
de donner ce type d' espaces mais vous
l'avez fait sur d'autres sujets qui
m'ont semblé tout aussi intéressant donc
je regarde assez régulièrement j'ai
regardé aussi l'interview de des spots
nique j'ai regardé l'interview sur
château déjà le garder natacha polony et
d'autres élise lucet enfin je n'ai
regardé quelques unes et je voulais vous
en félicite et je l' ai déjà fait dont
je le redis ici à votre antenne donc
vous connaissez la dernière question oui
qui est la dernière question assez pour
les générations futures hexagone essais
à la mer exemplaires vont laisser et
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations une bouteille à la mer
quelque chose d'impérissables oui c'est
à vous alors je pense que s'il ya trois
mots qu'on peut léguer aux générations
qui arrivent ce sont les mots humilité
altérité
et amour parce que il
faut de l'humilité pour se dire que on
est pas on n'est pas mieux ou pire que
les autres on est juste des êtres
humains il faut de l'altérité pour
comprendre que c'est parce que l'autre
est en face de moi et qu'il est un autre
mois que je ne peux que le traité avec
amour parce que je m'aime et que je peux
lui renvoyer cette image là et qu'il
peut me l'a renvoyé à son tour pour que
nous ayons une certaine forme d'harmonie
et l'amour aime ton prochain comme
toi-même participe de cette trilogie
c'est à dire que pour moi ça ne doit pas
être comme une injonction c'est ce qu'on
doit faire si on s'aime on arrive à
aimer les autres si on a du mal à
s'aimer on a peur de l'autre et des fois
on fait des choses qui ne sont pas très
acceptable et je pense que
l'humanisation commence par là se
considérer comme un homme un homme qui à
son alter ego auquel il veut il veut
apporter les mêmes choses qui leur est
mais à voir lui et à partir de là on
part sur des bases suffisamment saine
pour bâtir des choses suffisamment
grande est relevé de notre humanité nous
sommes des animaux mais des animaux
suffisamment
intelligents pour faire les choses
correctement oui magloire ki moon ou
merci merci à vous
com
[musique]